this video is brought to you by athletic
greens
[Music]
what's up guys michael here and today
we're talking about everyone's favorite
sex fluid shape-shifting norse god
that's right loki the trickster gad solo
series opened up a whole new level of
the mcu's cosmology introducing us to
the multiverse and the management agency
that oversees it the time variance
authority this bureaucracy which exists
outside of time and space gives zero f's
about loki or his glorious purpose and
proceeds to make his life miserable and
while it's plenty entertaining to watch
loki get caught in a tangled web of
bureaucracy we think there's actually a
lot more going on here in particular the
show explores the way in which
bureaucratic institutions can constrain
and even annihilate our ability to be
free and if the show is right then what
does this say about the real life
bureaucracies that play such a huge role
in our own lives to help us understand
we need to revisit the work of a very
dead author who had more than a few
things to say about bureaucracy franz
kapka we'll explain in this wisecrack
edition on loki the illusion of freedom
major spoilers ahead for the disney plus
series and some 100 year old czech
literature but before we get into it i
wanted to give a special shout out to
this week's sponsor athletic greens now
it might shock you to learn that i'm not
a professional athlete and the last time
i did competitive sports was in high
school but as i get older it's become
important to me that i take care of
myself and make the sort of decisions
that will help me stay healthy and this
is why i was excited to learn about
athletic greens athletic greens is an
all-in-one greens powder that's designed
to fill the nutritional gaps in your
diet and support your body's nutritional
needs along four pillars of support gut
health immune support energy and
recovery it uses 75 ingredients to give
you one of the most complete nutrition
formulas on the market including
vitamins and minerals prebiotics and
probiotics adaptogens and antioxidants
superfood complex and digestive enzymes
and mushroom complex and that's all very
impressive but one of the things i like
the most about athletic greens is that
it actually tastes good and it's super
easy to prepare you just fill your
shaker or bottle of choice with cold
water add a scoop of athletic greens
shake the heck out of it and drink i've
added it to my morning routine and it
takes less than a minute to have my
athletic greens ready to go in the past
i've tried to stay healthy by taking
like five different types of vitamins a
day but i always end up forgetting
athletic grains makes it easy to make
sure i'm getting all the nutrients my
body needs and while i'm unlikely to
transition into a career as a
professional athlete anytime soon it's
great to know that athletic greens is
nsf certified for sport meaning it's
approved for olympic athletes to get the
athletic greens immunity bundle that
comes with a one year supply of vitamin
d and five individual travel packs for
free with your first purchase go to
athleticgreens.com
wisecrack or click the link in the
description being healthy is hard so
make it easier with athletic greens and
now back to the show now before we can
unpack what's happening to this norse
god we first need to talk about this
czech author one of the most influential
modern writers franz kafka worked a day
job as a clerk in an insurance agency so
he was no stranger to unmitigated
bureaucracy unsurprisingly then his
writing frequently features protagonists
caught in a labyrinth of bureaucratic
systems often to the point that any
attempts to escape or even understand
these systems is rendered comically
futile this unique brand of absurd humor
in the face of soul-crushing oppression
has been appropriately dubbed
kafka-esque you've probably heard the
term used earnestly by tweed-clad
critics or ironically by over-educated
comedy writers yeah it's very
kafka-esque
because it's written by franz kafka now
kafka's novels and short stories have
been poured over by critics and
philosophers for decades leading to
wildly different and often contradictory
interpretations as a result the word
kafka s gets overused to describe
anything that's even vaguely
bureaucratic or just mildly inconvenient
i gotta pay taxes now that was up with
that that's messed up yo this cop to ask
church so what actually makes something
kafka s and what does that have to do
with loki wax and philosophical about
jet skis with a seemingly all-knowing
owen wilson jet ski magazine put it down
come on well when the series starts loki
is fresh off his campaign to take over
the earth asgard and the whole universe
so when he's detained by unnamed agents
from a mysterious authority for an
unknown crime he's understandably miffed
he's then subjected to a series of
bizarre intake procedures and eventually
put on trial for a crime that he still
doesn't fully comprehend this evokes
kafka's famous novel the trial in which
a man named joseph k is also arrested by
unnamed agents of an unspecified
authority for an unknown crime over the
course of the novel kay is subjected to
an utterly corrupt and unknowable
justice system which operates with
little logic and under no central
authority eventually he's executed
without ever knowing what crime he
supposedly committed unlike kaye loki
pretty quickly learns why he's been
arrested and who is doing the arresting
but he is rightly suspicious of the true
purpose of the tva and the nature of the
so-called time keepers he eventually
figures out they are merely synthetic
androids and that the entire tva was
created by some other even more
unknowable figure who exist even more
outside of time and space he also learns
that all of the agents of the tva were
pulled from other timelines they just
don't know it in this way the tva shares
a lot in common with the legal system in
the trial in the novel when k approaches
a priest about the falsity of his
accusations he's told it is not
necessary to accept everything is true
one must accept it as necessary writing
20 years later philosopher hannah arendt
points to this moment as the novel
summation of the tyranny of
bureaucracies saying lying for the sake
of necessity appears as something
sublime and a man who does not submit to
the machinery though submission may mean
his death is regarded as a sinner
against some kind of divine order that
is to say in this world submitting to
bureaucracy is more important than you
know protecting your own life and even
after the timekeepers are revealed to be
disney animatronics some agents still
swear loyalty to the tva not out of an
acceptance of truth but out of an
acceptance of its necessity i think
people are ready to hear a little truth
now you know like the tva is a lie but
what if it's a necessary one arent
describes a tendency of bureaucracies to
sustain themselves even without a real
leader in her book on violence she
writes bureaucracy is the form of
government in which everybody is
deprived of political freedom of the
power to act for the rule by nobody is
not no rule and where all are equally
powerless we have a tyranny without a
tyrant which is to say you don't need a
dictator in a funny hat to have a super
oppressive government but loki's
conflict with authority and search for
freedom goes way beyond the bureaucratic
halls of the tva see the bulk of the
show is dedicated to answering the
question what makes a loki a loki rather
than being an introspective character
study the question is treated more like
a detailed deconstruction of his
identity and autonomy when he's first
assessed by mobius he's shown clips from
his life up to that point along with
what would have happened in his original
timeline you weren't born to be king
loki you were born to cause pain and
suffering and death all so that others
can achieve their best versions of
themselves confronted with the reality
that all of his choices went to loki
admits that the free will he thought he
had was little more than a trick he
pulled on himself it's part of the
illusion
it's the cruel elaborate trick
conjured by the weak to inspire fear
the desperate play for control you do
know yourself it wasn't his own
individual agency that led him to do the
things he did it was his compulsion to
fulfill a societal role in this case the
role of god of mischief
similarly kafka wasn't only concerned
with the loss of free will under
authoritarian bureaucracies he also saw
individual autonomy itself as comically
irrelevant in a society where everyone
is more or less assigned a particular
role to perform while it's easy to read
kafka's work as a dark meditation on the
loss of freedom under bureaucratic
governments some philosophers argue that
it serves as a humorous satire of the
entire concept of free will philosopher
demetrius vardolakis writes that kafka's
humor is a response to the western
conception of freedom which he
tirelessly presents in his narratives
and that this response implies an
alternative conception of freedom in
this vein loki complicates what we think
freedom is namely the ability to simply
do what we want in reality even our
chosen actions can be done within the
context of performing a pre-ordained
role and in what's arguably his most
famous work the metamorphosis he
explores this idea through a traveling
salesman named gregor samhsa who wakes
up one morning to find he's been
transformed into an insect sadly there
is no alligator gregory rather than
worrying about the existential
implications of this transformation
gregor gregor's first thought is about
how he will be able to keep his job to
provide for his family as time goes on
and gregor's condition doesn't improve
his family increasingly neglects him
reacting with utter disgust every time
they see him he eventually passes away
and the family rejoices harsh the
metamorphosis derives its ironic humor
from treating the fantastical and
bewildering as mundane and tiresome loki
does much of the same infinity stones
we actually got a lot of those
yeah some of the guys use them as paper
weights or you know
this if it were me
this is where i would hide
but on a deeper level kafka's story is a
disturbing deconstruction of
individualism once he is stripped from
his role as family provider gregor is
also effectively stripped of his
self-worth the fact that he's more
concerned about his financial and social
status than you know
being a [ __ ] bug is an ironic
commentary on the burdens placed on us
by society we see a similar
metamorphosis happen with loki once he
finds himself stripped of his role as
the god of mischief he has a full-blown
identity crisis when he eventually
submits and starts working for the tva
he is tasked with literally finding
himself well a variant of himself but
still meeting sylvie he's confronted
with a version of himself who is
singularly obsessed with her own
glorious purpose namely bringing down
the tva he decides to help her achieve
this goal mostly because he's fallen in
love with himself which which is you
know a pretty low-key thing to do but
once they finally meet the man behind
the curtain or he who remains it's
revealed that even their acts of
defiance and rebellion were all a part
of their set path and that they've been
playing right into his hands the entire
time no we broke out of your little game
that's how we got here no
wrong
every
step
you took to get here
clementus the void
i
paved the road
you
you just walk down it in this way the
show presents us with a world where in
the face of all powerful agencies upheld
by unwitting agents free will is nothing
more than an illusion and you don't have
to be controlled by a shadowy management
agency operating outside of time and
space to fall victim to this plight
because real freedom is often subsumed
under structures of power like
governments as vardo lochus puts it we
think that we have the freedom to
exercise our will only by forgetting
that power is exercised not simply by
delimiting our freedom but by confining
our will to power's own operation
perpetuation the more we exercise our
free will the more power proliferates in
other words when we feel like we're
freely participating in or working for
some large organization or power like a
big corporation what we're actually
doing is sacrificing and ultimately
losing that very freedom freedom
paradoxically ends up being the
prerequisite to being controlled or as
judge renslayer puts it free will
only one person gets free will
the one in charge and while not an
interdimensional time cop kafka agrees
he even argues that our own individual
ambitions can be as oppressive as the
forces of bureaucracy his short story a
hunger artist is about a performer who
makes a living starving himself for the
entertainment of others like gay turn of
the century david blaine the performer
though singularly obsessed with his
craft laments the fact that he's only
legally allowed to fast for 40 days lest
he you know starve to death when this
restriction is lifted mainly due to a
lack of public interest in his act he's
finally allowed to achieve his goal of
starving himself to death here the irony
is that this guy's greatest dream is
literally the cause of his own very
hungry demise loki has a similar
confrontation with his own individual
ambition over the course of the series
his catchphrase i am burdened with
glorious purpose
begins to change in meaning with the
emphasis less on the glorious purpose
and more on the burden when he finally
escapes the tva and reaches the end of
time he's confronted with the
possibility of finally getting what he
always desired you want the infinity
gauntlet
yours
throne of asgard
no problem but unlike the hunger artist
doubling down on the whole starvation
thing loki decides to relinquish his
ambitions by now he doesn't seem to care
much about taking down the tva and
exposing the truth either he simply
wants to spend his life even if it is an
artificial one with sylvie in a way he
is freed from his shackles not by
overthrowing his oppressors but from
laying down the burden of his ambition i
thought a throat
i just
i just want you to be okay
silvie on the other hand comes to the
opposite conclusion having been burdened
her whole life with the task of
destroying the tva and killing whoever
created it she finds it impossible to
abandon that quest but in a truly
kapka-esque turn once she finally
achieves her goal she's left alone and
defeated but rather than starving
herself to death she simply ruined the
whole of reality
[Music]
hey it happens to the best of us and
despite her actions the tva persists and
on multiple timelines under the
leadership of an even more oppressive
authority kafka-esque indeed and oh yeah
loki is even more screwed than he was at
the beginning but if the show and kafka
are right about the way in which
bureaucratic institutions slowly chip
away at our freedom and individuality
what does this mean for us you don't
have to be arrested for an unknown crime
to think
nothing good sure kafka had his gripes
about 20th century bureaucracy but dude
would lose his [ __ ] if he could see the
modern world as anthropologist david
graber argues in his book the utopia of
rules bureaucracy has become the water
in which we swim and our contemporary
times are an age of total
bureaucratization in that it's so
ubiquitous we almost don't even
recognize it anymore we may think we're
swimming freely but we're simply going
with the current from excessive
standardized testing in grade school to
megalithic prison systems to the 14
pages of paperwork you fill out every
time you go to the eye doctor
bureaucracy is everywhere increasingly
every job requires higher education
certificate programs and written tests
to be hired and increasingly those hired
office workers find more and more of
their time sucked up by administrative
bureaucratic tasks and what graber not
so fondly calls
jobs and he argues that this bureaucracy
ultimately serves to make us less free
by encouraging conformity and rule
following and situating us in a society
run by rules that are enforced by
violence
we're not the tva's synthetic android
drones living outside of time and space
but if kafka engraver are right
bureaucracy and the institutions that
govern our lives are still entirely
capable of slowly chipping away at our
freedom so what do we do and is there
any way to fight back let's turn to our
two favorite loki's or is it lokai the
original god of mischief decides to
accept the systems that govern him take
over the keys to the timeline from he
who remains who is absolutely king the
conqueror and try to change bureaucracy
from the inside you take over and return
to the tva as its benevolent rulings and
in the meantime they'll try to live his
best life sylvia on the other hand would
argue that these systems are beyond
reform and need to be burned the f down
so we can start over and stop filling
out so much god damn paperwork but what
do you guys think are any of us truly
free or are we merely at the whims of
the social structures and bureaucratic
systems that surround us let us know
what you think in the comments either
way smash that like and subscribe button
but do it because you want to not
because i told you to
big thanks to our patrons for all your
support and as always thanks for
watching later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you